make it count if you can't connect with
yourself it's gonna be really hard to
connect with other people the scariest
thing that you're afraid to put out is
the thing that you have to go off and
share it's the only way to things in
business you don't delegate are the
marketing in the checkbook my favorite
news of all time by the way just the
came to me I have to tell you well thank
you I love this is amazing this is gel
polish and I'm sitting in a genius
Network headquarters after a two-day
genius X meeting which is our hundred K
group and I've got this guy Evan
Carmichael who the hell are you how do
you describe who you are to people that
say hello so what do you do so you mean
you do a lot of things you've got this
whole message about believe but uh like
if this was your last opportunity to
tell the world what you actually do and
the only thing that was left were all
these videos of you on YouTube
what would you say doesn't matter to me
that was the last thing I had to say
like go go believe in yourself that's
about you not me
I think you should have a hard time
though explaining what you do like I
think that's the right thing I think
that I don't think you can just check a
box and say that's what I do I think if
you can actually just check the box and
say that's me you hate your life
yeah you should have a lot of things
that make it complicated so for me I
think I'm probably best known for my
youtube channel I'm trying to help
inspire entrepreneurs people use my
channel as a way of believing themselves
more than what we do is I'll have my own
content and then also mix up and DJ
other successful people and always show
the positive side of their message yeah
something that is seen through the lens
of believe so that if you want more
belief in yourself then there's always
content for you every day to go to that
can inject some positivity into your
life so the word believe is it's
interesting to me because I I think you
know a belief means you're just not sure
so when someone says I believe this or I
believe in God or I believe in whatever
so what does believe mean to you I think
it's the opposite when you believe in
something it's it's at the core of who
you are not doesn't mean it's the truth
though is it if I believe that this you
know the ceilings made out of chocolate
and I really a hundred percent believe
that that that's not true though I think
that's what entrepreneurs do we create
things that aren't true yeah we make it
up and make
real exactly so we make a ceiling full
of chocolate do you want to help people
what what do you really like what does
that your core what the hell does that
really mean to you I think everybody has
Michael Jordan level talent it's
something I think I think everybody is a
genius to your to your slogan everybody
is a genius most people either one have
no idea what it is because they haven't
tried enough stuff they just got locked
in on one path and now they hit their
life or two they found the thing that
they want to do but they don't believe
in it enough to chase it down and
instead they're going to become an
accountant there's something else that
they don't like doing in ninety five
percent of America wakes up and drives
to a job that they hate absolutely and
that bothers me yeah because they have
Michael Jordan level talent genius
that's something you just don't know
what it is and you got to go find it
and it's okay to be where you are but
where you start this empty where you
finish right and so most people don't
have a positive environment to help them
get to where they need to go and so
that's what I try to do in a virtual way
a lot of people who watch my videos say
Avenue the only one in my life who
believes in me and that's sad like I
don't even know who you are right but
because of the content we're injecting
positivity so that if people around them
are all negative tell them they can't do
it or come from really bad upbringing
and there is no positive role models you
can get that through books you can get
that to videos you can get that through
podcasts and the more that you choose to
surround yourself with that content the
more it'll lift you up maybe not like
this big moment but time time time it
keeps injecting into your head and you
say huh like it maybe I can do that if I
should believe in myself just a little
bit more even though my parents say that
I suck maybe maybe you know Joe Joe's
saying some stuff that seems to make
sense to me I mean I'll just try it yeah
and then just hope just a little bit of
hope as all people need to actually go
and make a radical change in their life
and so I want to try to be that and I
think every entrepreneur wants to try to
be that in their own way and the amazing
people in your network
everybody's mission-driven in some way
we all want to have a positive impact
and somehow I think your purpose comes
from your pain my biggest pain was
struggling as an entrepreneur so I want
to help others yours the diction helping
others and everybody who was around in
this meeting to your main audience of
who you want to help as entrepreneurs my
main audience who will want to help his
entrepreneurs my audience that I have
attracted has been has been worldwide
because people still want belief
regardless if they want to be an
entrepreneur I can help you way more
deeply if you're Purpose Driven have a
mission a message you want to be an
entrepreneur I can go further with you
then I wouldn't know what to do with
someone who had addiction yeah I
couldn't tell you what to do I could
give them hope and give them some videos
to watch and and say go talk to Joe but
I haven't gone through it so I can't
help but a lot of addicts are watching
my videos and it's the only positivity
in their life yeah so I didn't set out
thinking I'm gonna have addicts watching
my videos but as a result of just the
positivity the message people end up
wanting to subscribe well let me ask you
when you first started doing your videos
did you have this idea that you just
want to be speaking to people worldwide
was it right from the get-go or was this
more of an accident it started for me
because I'm a visual learner and I'd
rather see something then read something
or hear something
auditory is that she divorced her me I
consume zero podcasts cuz I have to
really focus hard if we were doing this
and I couldn't see you'd be much more
difficult for me okay so I started
making videos as there was a response
that people were asking me questions my
most iconic series is my top 10 rules of
success I started that just as a test
because a buddy of mine was hating on
kanye west on a blog post and I said
listen Kanye's done a lot of things that
he deserves to be attacked for maybe but
he's also a genius and you should be
able to learn from him even if you don't
like a lot of what he does at least
that's my mindset I love learning from
people who I disagree with because they
still have something to teach me you
could still learn something from them to
make you a better you you're not trying
to be the next anybody how'd it be the
best me and I can learn that from
different people and when you can learn
to learn from people who you disagree
with is when you actually start to learn
yeah I agree that that's a really good
perspective because a lot of people
just one change to the choir they just
want to hear from people that have to
share their same beliefs but the the
real way to truly understand someone is
to actually talk and listen to people
that have completely polar opposite
beliefs to go back to believe that you
may have and even in the way they do it
negatively you can learn a positive way
to go off and do it so with Kanye we
made a list of all of his quotes and
videos that I resonated with and then we
shared that because it's a really
negative message around him and I'm
saying I'm not gonna ignore that I'm
just saying hey here's something else
for the conversation John Legend
you know John Legend so John and Kanye
are friends which already seems kind of
weird because John Legend seems to be
the humble nice easygoing guy and Kanye
is doing Kanye things right there in a
bar in Chicago and John Legend his name
is John Stevens says I have a really
old-school voice you know I feel like
I'm I have an old-school voice and I
don't know I don't fit in as much as
these other singers Kanye says you
should call yourself the legend
and John Stephen says I can't do that
I'm just getting started I'm gonna call
myself the legend like it's not an ego
play like no you need to own it you need
to call yourself the legend and so he
went out John Legend yeah that's belief
right like that's for me that's why I
love it cuz the message of hope believe
optimism and it's Kanye believing in his
friend to push them even if you hate
Kanye you can learn from that to say hey
maybe there's somebody in my life who I
need to just give a little bit more
belief in and encourage them to do
something positive yeah right yep that's
what I love doing I believe in the area
of addiction hope heals so whenever you
are around someone that in many cases
believes in you more than you believe in
yourself and I've been in that situation
yeah my own recovery where I just felt
suicidal I felt completely down and out
I felt hopeless and I'll be a you know a
meeting as an example and there'll be a
group of people that are there
supporting me and there's something
about that that is incredibly valuable
and maybe in a lot of ways that's you
know how some people interact with your
your work I also have a belief which is
that a lot of people that are out there
teaching it it's a way of keeping
themselves into a motivated State and
and I want to get your opinion on this
for you in your own life and also in the
world of personal development where
people are out there you know motivating
encouraging inspiring be it very
strategic and giving tactical
methodologies or just simply you know
rah-rah inspiration what what drives you
to do this so you are out there wanting
to spread hope wanting to inspire
wanting to encourage one help why I
think your purpose comes from your pain
my biggest pain was in starting up my
first business I was 19 and I struggled
I turned down these high-paying jobs to
do a business make three hundred dollars
a month and own 30% of that company and
I struggled and I was too embarrassed to
tell my friends that I had no money I
was living the entrepreneur life I can't
come up with you because I'm too busy
hustling I really 20 bucks for Pete's
and beer was too much mhm and so I lived
that life and I eat the same bean salad
for lunch every day because it filled me
up and was cheap and when we closed the
sale we went to McDonald's
three of us and got a large french fries
and split it between the three of us
because that's what we could afford
and to this day mcdonald's french fries
still is victory like i smell it and I
just think victory because we celebrated
so many times over McDonald's fries Wow
even though it's super unhealthy and we
don't go that often but the smell of
fries just brings back the memories of
elation happiness that's how we
celebrated and so I struggled so much
and I told my partner that I quit on him
one day and just I felt such
worthlessness as a human and I
eventually got out of it and sold my
business and went on to do other things
but I think the thing that will fill you
up forever in life that you can never
get enough of is helping people who are
currently in the hell that you came from
yeah totally forever that's your purpose
for life so helping especially startup
entrepreneurs like I love everybody in
this room but for me my heart is with
the pure startup who are trying to
figure out how to get going because I
still see the pain and suffering and so
that's gonna help that's gonna be my
thing forever the how will change with
this YouTube whether it's VR or hologram
Evan coming at you you know that will
change a lot of times but the the Y is
forever and so that's this is the best
way that I know how to use my
capabilities to serve as many people as
possible and it's what I've made my
mission what are some examples of people
that you have helped
have you ever anyone say you know you
saved my life you know I was gonna
commit suicide I mean you've heard of
bazillion things from your followers so
what are some examples of how you've
impacted people that you're really proud
of this was unexpected
because for me I was thinking
entrepreneurs and I was never suicidal
and I was never massively depressed and
I never did drugs and I was never on the
brink and I had amazing parents and a
great upbringing so hearing people's
stories of how the content has helped
them blows my mind so there was one
where a woman she commented on the video
saying she was going to go and drive off
a bridge
she committed like I'm gonna I'm getting
my car and I gotta go drive off a bridge
and in my life because it's not worth
any more and for whatever reason she put
on one of my videos and was listening
into it as she was going down
I decided to turn around and go home
like I never yeah never thought like
people and that's it you wish more
because it's not it's not native to me
it's a foreign land I've never had
suicidal thoughts yeah my favorite
comment of all time was we did a video
on a black entrepreneur and some guys
left a comment and he said I have been
growing up my parents always told me
that black people were [ __ ] and you
couldn't learn anything from them and
this video showed me that I could learn
something from a black man Wow
interesting so now we're attacking
racism Brian it's like and I'm Canadian
you know we grow up with we still have
some racism I guess but we grow up with
all different kinds of cultures it was
not my intent to go out and say I'm here
to try to solve racism but what happens
is people they people come in for people
who look like them this is actually my
secret ninja project of all time behind
the channel people come in for people
who look like them women want to learn
from women and and black mane want to
learn from black men and Asians want it
writers want to learn from writers and
marketers want to learn from marketers
right that's how they come in initially
yeah and then they built some kind of
trust in me in what I'm creating but I
don't care so much about whether you're
a woman or black or anything I care
about belief so all the content is still
filtered through belief and so they
built up enough trust in me that then
when I recommend this black entrepreneur
he's willing to put his parents judgment
aside for three minutes because I
recommended it just to see and then poof
it like changes his entire perspective
that's what that's amazing for me like
that that comment blew my mind yeah
that's awesome
so what does the logo mean so uh it's a
paper airplane and it's an airplane
taking off and my my youtube you see an
airplane taking off to me that
represents entrepreneurship taking off
against the wind you're soaring to new
heights you're you know trying to see in
a whole new world but it's a paper
airplane because you don't have the
resources at the beginning because
you're not supposed to be flying just
it's not some jet plane that's taking
off so you want to give them the
resources yeah and I want you to believe
in yourself you shouldn't be able to fly
to the crazy heights as a paper airplane
you supposed to take off and then crash
right so I want I want that to happen
believe is my one word I think everybody
has a single most important core value
when you figure out what that is
you can then design your life and
business around it so then I'm thinking
what is belief sound like so it should
be an airplane because it's the logo
when we first did it it sounded like a
crop duster kind of going over I think
that's not really believed so let's turn
it into a jet plane that then breaks a
sound barrier
so you see a paper airplane but it
sounds like a jet plane that then breaks
the sound barrier and that's at the
start of all my videos yeah so that's
it's a belief symbol for me do you know
I think about the origin of the word
entrepreneur the one that I know is from
French on entrepreneur yeah it's from
john baptiste say most people don't know
that yeah first recorded use of the word
entrepreneur was in 1804 from john
baptiste a french guy and he said as an
individual that takes resources from a
lower yield to a higher yield
resources from a lower level of
productivity to a higher level of
productivity so a lot of people will
think of you know an entrepreneur is a
you know there's an axe and someone
invents a chainsaw too you know chop
down a tree but when you can take
someone's thinking from one level to a
higher level
that's entrepreneurship and so anything
in terms of capabilities or skills or
you know whenever you're just improving
it
that's entrepreneurship and I think
almost all world problems you know can
be solved through and will be solved and
some only can be solved through
entrepreneurs 5% yeah yeah and I love I
love carrying that mental like I want to
stop blaming corporations and stop
blaming the government you you think
there's a problem you go solve it okay
it's never been easier yeah yeah well so
I've got some specific questions here
that I want to get some answers to why
did you write your book your one-word
and what's it about so I didn't want to
write a book
my agent wanted me to write a book and
he said well to open doors and they get
into meetings and to get no need to
write a book I don't need any like it's
a new world my YouTube channel can open
doors to me
I don't need a book and then I was as I
was thinking about a book idea the one
word was something that I started to
play with myself I start as a marketing
problem what's my
tagline and what's my tagline gonna be
for my business and then it became
really it should be a personal tagline
that I bring to my business I should
start with me that then my value was
injected into the business not the
business has his own thing so then I
said well what do I stand for and then
that causes crazy you know internal
search and I came up with the word
believe but I thought it was too simple
it's too simple and Who am I
who my to be believed like it's such a
big and it's crazy how often we talk
ourselves down from Big Ideas we don't
even need our friends to do it we will
talk ourselves down from the crazy Big
Ideas whom I had to be the belief guy
and that's the more I just slept on I
liked it I said I'm gonna I'm gonna do a
crazy thing and rebuild my whole
business around belief yeah but I like
testing things so I was tested with my
email newsletter okay I'm just gonna
write an email newsletter on believe I
got the highest conversion rates the
highest open range the highest
click-through rates my sister wrote back
to me said hey Evan I'm actually reading
your newsletter now it's like the the
the compliment and punch to the stomach
that only you know your sister can give
you right so then I did it I did a video
on believe on my channel and my agent
hated it when I sent it to him didn't
like it but you know what I liked it so
I'll put it up and just see who cares if
it fails it fails my best video to that
point had a hundred thousand views in a
year and a super pump like grow my
channel hundred thousand views one year
it's a good video this one did a hundred
thousand views in a month and then
quickly rode outputs around to two and
half million or something now and so
like there's something to this belief
thing not because it's a good strategy
but because it makes me more alive it's
more authentic to write what I love
doing
I love spreading that message not
everybody agrees with it you know it's
hard to hate on believe but some people
do yeah great it's not gonna be your
tribe I'm soon as I'm talking to you
thinking about you know if there's more
people that are optimistic or
pessimistic what do you think I think
humans are good and most people are
actually optimistic they're just limited
in their thinking and in that shows up
as maybe pessimist exactly I think most
people hate their lives but I think I
think people are built to serve and they
want to do more and they want to be
optimistic
well I'm actually
thinking about knocking off your YouTube
channel because you actually know how to
get more use the three because you have
that skill at a much better rate and and
focus than I currently do but I'm hoping
you will teach me all this stuff which
one of the you know reasons for doing
this interview great it's a sneaky way
to you know kind of learn how to take it
suck it all out let's do it but I'm
thinking if I just like do spoof videos
of all of your videos but call it don't
believe and just say the polar opposite
I've almost thinking we could maybe this
could work you don't want to do that I'm
kidding of course I know do you know
people make smooth videos of you people
would do
yes spin-offs or spoof do that to
yourself
do you like made fun of your own
messages some likes people say I look
like Nicolas Cage and so I made a video
of how Nicolas Cage looks like everybody
and we put Nicolas Cage on the Statue of
Liberty and Nicolas Cage on Princess
Leia and on Yoda and that's Ben
everybody looks like Nicolas Cage and
then I wore like a Nicholas Cage mask at
the end of it yeah but I probably don't
do enough of that
I haven't tapped into my humor enough I
think it's not as entertaining a channel
that it could be you hang around a lot
of people that you know have big
followings on YouTube and whatnot how do
you internalize the people that attack
you the haters the people that talk I
mean yeah what are your thoughts about
it you start by feeling sorry for them
mm-hmm because the the highlight of
their day is coming to your video and
leave on a negative comment mm-hmm like
how bad a situation do they have to be
and to do that and if you believe at the
core that people are good and they want
to serve but then they're acting this
behavior then I feel sorry for them yeah
right the second thing is I look for is
there any hidden truth that I can learn
from because people often can only
accept feedback when it's sugar-coated
and say hey Joe I love your videos and
this was really great and I have like
one little tiny suggestion if that's the
only way you can take feedback you lose
right like maybe the person is yelling
racist comments at you and says that you
absolutely suck but then gives you
something in there about why if you can
ignore that and just see oh like hey I
can learn from that and get better then
you go and then a third thing is I think
if you can
engage with the haters not to try to
change them but to show your community
how you engage with haters as an
inspiration so somebody will leave a
negative comment on your video said Joe
you suck and then you say hey man thank
you for the love or however you would
feel proud to respond to somebody people
who are watching say that's so
interesting how Joe responded to that
person that negative person yeah and
maybe they learn from that and put it
into their own life whether in a job or
relationship or anything else now I've
had a lot of haters come back and say
hey man you know I was just in a really
bad spot at that time but I'm not even
trying to change the hater I'm trying to
be a source of inspiration for the
people watching the dialogue that's
happening right well in look at the end
of the day a lot of people will not go
out in an attempt to do something
because of fear because they don't want
to be rejected they don't want to be
insulted and so I think the ability to
you know speak to it live through it
talk about it is important and there's
all but also being able to look at what
people are actually saying in and try to
find the gold
in what a lot of people would perceive
is just you know attacks is is a really
useful so I set this in your group I
think entrepreneurs and leaders are
trees a tree breathing poison carbon
dioxide eats it grows from it and then
spits out positivity oxygen for the
world yeah so if if you see yourself as
that then you have to take on the
negativity and you have to take on the
judgment because you're gonna grow from
that and then create positivity for
whether the world or the people around
you I think people are built to either
serve the world or the 25 closest people
to them one or the other but you're
still built to serve and so if you are a
tree then you want to go off and attack
anything that feels uncomfortable if
your hearts going like this
boom boom boom boom boom you go off and
do it and so you attack judgment a
chocolate you have eyes of judgment on
you you're worried about it then you
have to go off and do that thing just to
show yourself that you can so you get
stronger
I love Doritos and when you're on a diet
they say take the junk food out of the
house I think that's a good starting
point but I think ultimately makes you
weaker
because you're training yourself that
you can't be around the stuff right so
that if you're ever at a party or you
going vacation now you're spazzing out
eating all the junk food yeah so my
weakness is Doritos
I love Doritos this week well also on
Saturdays I'll eat whatever I want so
like every Saturday we got the redose
but but six days a week it's super
healthy I wouldn't publicly be saying
this it's not a good thing then I need
to I got to jump into the judgement
you're gonna throw judging at me then
I'll say it even louder right that's
training so I have this giant baggage we
use we go to Costco and buy like the
biggest one of all time the huge ones
and I have it right next me on my desk
yeah at all times yeah
just because Dan the Doritos because I'm
stronger than the Doritos
now you may not be able to do that at
the beginning because you have such a
big yeah you know if you wanna know my
opinion on that sort of stuff well okay
first off look yeah anything that you
are doing to steal yourself or build up
some sort of resistance against things
that just call out to you if someone is
a full-blown addict I mean you know if
you can handle it you shouldn't be like
if you're if you're a food attic you
know you shouldn't be leaving a bunch of
things that are vices
laying around I mean it's like I'm an
alcoholic let me keep booze around the
house to tempt me so I mean it and how
you interact with it has a lot to do
with the level of unmanageability right
but I mean if you're using something to
build up your endurance to build up your
resistance I mean you you certainly can
you know you you you you certainly could
use that in a in a positive way I would
not encourage anyone with addictions to
try to test it because if you play with
snakes you're gonna get bit and you know
if you don't really want to eat Doritos
you probably never should have them
around you know but if you keep them
around but see you really want doritos
and I think if you're eating them every
week cuz you have one day that you eat
anything you wanted to think that I
think that's a weird way of just to find
it but I'll let you I'll look at the
degree doesn't say I'm stronger than you
Doritos and I'll like get myself you
know Saturday then I'll eat them yeah
yeah I love it I think the derivatives
are stronger than you on Saturdays yes
they're so but so here's another one
most people wake up in the morning
America what are they doing first thing
they look in the mirror and they say
good morning let the stress begin before
that what do they do
pee complain before that before they
like in their heads or you mean behavior
so behavior the first thing they do they
actually physically do as soon as they
wake up yeah you don't do it but most of
America does it drink a glass of water I
don't what come on no way they should
let the most people they hit this news
button oh okay
yeah um you know it's funny I mean look
Mel Robbins is a friend of yours no runs
and friend of mine I'm very different
than Mel on this okay the like so
five-second rule like I hate the snooze
button so first off the snooze button is
what you set a goal last night
then I'm gonna wake up at 6 a.m. or
whatever and the very first thing you
say is I am NOT gonna hit my goal that's
the snooze button yeah you're teaching
your mindset there's a whole bunch of
see that's the reason I didn't pick that
immediately because it's so I'm solar
you're so again I'm so dream and not do
yeah of course what the hell do people
do when they wake up in the morning it's
the mindset there's a whole bunch of
health reasons why you shouldn't do it I
don't care about that I care about the
mindset you're teaching yourself I don't
hit my goals I don't hit my goals and so
the I still have a great day if you
training yourself every morning I don't
hit my goals Mel's advice is take the
cell phone and put it outside the
kitchen or in the kitchen or somewhere
it's in the room yeah I think that makes
you weaker because you can't handle
having the phone next you because he hit
the snooze so for me if you need to do
that I see it as a crutch yeah but
what's the point of a crutch you're
injured you have a crutch yeah
eventually you want to get rid of the
crutch because you can walk again so if
you're hitting the snooze all the time
you need to have the phone out in the
living room great but ultimately I want
the phone back in the room right just to
show myself even if I thought that I was
gonna sneeze and that was something bad
for me I I need to have the phone right
next to me and that's why you only go
for the day well is hit hit off and get
up and be tired and have stuff in my
eyes and whatever but right hey so it's
I mean whatever whatever works it's the
same thing for judgment I think you need
to attack it if you if you are
potentially feeling the burn of people's
eyes on you you have to go off and do
that thing just to teach yourself that
you're strong enough to do that thing
right and then as you do that thing even
if you suck because you tie yourself
esteem to the effort not the result even
if you suck
that's an inspiration for yourself and
to other people like made look what
Joe's trying whether you hit the thing
or not like you tried most people are
too afraid to even try yeah so boom boom
boom your hearts going crazy you have to
go up and do that thing yeah even if
it's not an expression oh no I mean I
agree I it's like I I've always loved
the same you know do one thing every day
that scares you which doesn't mean go
run out in front of traffic I mean
there's stupid things that you can do
there just but that's what people go by
default well what if somebody says jump
off a bridge okay but there's there's
you've played small a million times
today without even thinking about it I
think people play small by default I
think we just play with them you know
even you meet everybody I'm walking on a
straight avid dance studio right in the
Bible I play small intentionally it's
not just default I'm you know well fix
the card did not it's 25 minute walk
from my place to a dance studio mm-hmm
I have music gun in my ears yeah so I'm
dancing yeah I get to a busy
intersection young and Sheppard in
Toronto 200 people around what do I do
dance no I stopped yeah I was dancing I
stopped because it's people around right
right I'm doing just like a little head
nod and then I catch it like what the
heck am i doing what do I care about I
was expressing myself through dance and
then I stopped because there's people
around me all of a sudden catching that
means I have to now dance bigger I got a
dance up a storm in the middle of this
crazy intersection not getting anybody's
face and say hey look at me but just do
it
the thing is I had probably done that
walk 500 times and never noticed that I
would stop dancing mmm we play small by
default
until dense when you catch it what do
you do
you catch it and don't do the thing that
scares you it's better not to catch it
because you're teaching yourself that I
play small when I'm scared
so you have to do the thing and then
celebrate it even if you suck at the
thing because you did the thing that
scared you that builds a muscle all
these entrepreneurs who have these
amazing big bold visions and goals for
themselves that they want to create this
better world that they can't get out and
dance in the street didn't did all the
muscle you travel it's a thousand pounds
you can you live ten there's no way
that's going to happen until you can do
this
I'm trying to think if I actually would
consider that like a form of bravery or
just not it's probably a low self-esteem
thing I don't know if I did be that easy
for me to dance this is judgment it's
why like you should get up and dance
here you know it's just judgment who
cares who cares why do you dance
together right now no you should do it
on your own because you're more scared
I'll dance I feel like but who cares
what but what you know what my wife
thinks about your dancing like that
you're not gonna dance because she's
sitting there right in front of you
smiling already right who cares and then
you celebrate that and it's not about
how good a dancer you were because if
you practice you can get great at any
dancing it's just a skill set at the
beginning you're gonna suck what a diva
it's not that I can't dance this is a
certain place you know but I want to
attack that why as long as it's not
against like if it's a funeral and
you're gonna stand up the front and
dance okay you want to be sensitive to
other people's you know emotions are
going through but ya know I guess that
would ya right but you could dance here
that's true right good and if you're
like oh my god that sounds a little
crazy
great yeah then you have to do it and
you teach yourself so so are you
suggesting the putting yourself in in
continuous situations that stretch you
or just like like really what's the
message behind all it so there's two
formats one you get an idea you do
something mm-hmm I did your idea comes
from somewhere do it do it don't judge
it because it won't make sense because
maybe there's the ceiling is chocolate
yeah if you only think through what
makes sense you'll never do anything
great in your life period so you get an
idea trust it comes from somewhere and
then go do it just take action
immediate action because we overthink
and overplaying and / perfection it
ourselves away from doing anything
because tomorrow you'll wake up a
different person so you have to do it
you mediate the decisions you make when
you're feeling bold and unstoppable or
actually the right ones for you you have
to take immediate action on them because
tomorrow you wake up a different person
yeah you've lost that confidence in
bravery so idea action the second one is
your heart's beating like this boom boom
if you catch it action same thing yeah
go do it
no I agree well you won't even catch it
though
that's the thing I think so then you'd
be gentle on yourself I probably played
small 100 times already today I just
never caught it but when you catch it
you have to go into the thing for me
coming in here in raising the energy and
maybe yelling a few people you know
everybody here has had more financial
success and I have and I'm telling them
what they need to be doing because that
idea came from somewhere so I have to do
it the intention is always good maybe I
think nothing is fatal if I'm calling
out one of your members and and I'm
pushing him hard and and he just totally
disagrees with me and is totally
offended and is pissed off at me I'm
gonna do everything I can to make it up
to him and to you for causing this scene
and and pissing off your customer right
or your friend right right but so it's
not fatal I can come back from it
because I'll work my face off
whatever you need ever in life I will
say yes to until you've forgiven me for
this thing because it'll destroy me that
I disappointed letting people down is my
biggest fear of all time yeah I hate
disappointing people yeah I hate
disappointing yourself too I think we'll
let ourselves down all the time we hate
disappointing others you'll do way more
when you commit to somebody else and you
will do for yourself right so but that
idea comes from somewhere I might be
nervous and scared do go you got to do
it no I mean look in life you either you
know you're the frozen stiff or you're
moving scared I mean anything that's
that is got some level of importance to
you unless you know there are some
people that are you know incapable of
you know being a sociopath or something
capable of feeling things but if you
know I mean if you see someone that
you're attracted to and you want to ask
out on the date there's gonna be a
certain level of nervousness or a ton of
it that almost immobilizes you but the
ability to just you know go through with
it you know what I learned early on is
you know whatever you fear and don't
face controls you whatever you fear and
you take steps to face you can either
control it or you can at least get a lot
better towards it and it is a continuous
effort to swim against the stream at
times I mean even public speaking you
know I mean probably the largest group I
think I've ever spoken in front of for
you know an hour's 5,000 people
you know I mean when I was first
starting out I couldn't speak in front
of 20 people without just I was so in
cramming my heart was beating out of my
chest but I just knew that if I ever
wanted to make certain impacts and I you
know had to do that you know I was very
introverted and shy growing up I don't
feel comfortable in cocktail parties but
also you know I've learned how to train
myself to go out and do stuff because
you know there's stuff I want to do and
that requires that level of stuff so I
think putting yourself out there so so
let me give some context to because we
mentioned the group earlier so you were
here earlier today yeah you were
interviewing Dean grazi OSI so Dean's
you know been one of my friends and
genius Network members since 2006 and
you know this is a group with people
it's my genius X group so people pay
$100,000 a year to be in the group and
so we came in you did the interview but
then you did some Q&A to kind of talk
about what you actually do behind the
scenes and so YouTube is your platform
your preferred platform of choice so
let's talk about how did you how did you
build this thing how did you draw it
let's kind of go through some of the
systems for people out there that have
something they want to share with the
world and you encourage and inspire
people to do that so how do you build
yours it starts with deciding to do it
so why why YouTube why does it matter
YouTube is the best place to build a
long-term brand to have a huge impact if
your mission driven if it's not a quick
cycle thing you want to you want to pump
it in and then a year get out that's
Instagram
instagrams the fastest way to grow but
is this hamster wheel that you're
constantly on YouTube the videos that
you make in five years will still be
generating leads traffic business
awareness whatever your causes your
business your mission forever it takes
longer to build up and get started with
it but being able to create content for
YouTube when a platform where the
content lives forever and every other
platform even podcasting people aren't
going back and and watching the earlier
episodes it's the only thing that that
the content generally lasts forever
and so I think it should be the default
home for anybody who's a thought leader
who wants to raise awareness and get
their message out and then you use that
as your base and then you take the the
audio you put into a podcast you take
the best one-minute clip from that you
put it
gram so the other networks are amazing
but YouTube is at home now how do you do
it depends on what your gift is so if
you're a thought leader then you want to
teach me to think like you think you're
a thought leader I want to think the way
you think your weird duck you see the
world differently right you'll walk in
here and you'll see it differently I
want to know the things that are natural
for you like the snooze most people hit
the snooze
you don't yeah why how how did you get
there what's wrong with that
when you get into your car what do you
see how do you see the world what the
meditation stuff you do was like all of
this stuff that for you now has become
normal to most of the world is weird
mm-hmm so so teaching me to think the
way that you think and then willingness
to try all those different things and
what stuck and why not right that's a
thought leader other people could be
entertainers other people could be
singers right I guess for this audience
is more entrepreneurial yeah right so
you're a thought leader you're on a
mission help me feel the cause this is
how you beat the big companies coca-cola
is not going to win because of them
their CEO caring about a cause mm-hmm
that's how you win your story your
personal story and I fought against it I
didn't want to put myself front and
center i associated me being upfront
with ego but it's actually me being
selfish because people will learn from
my story my journey and if I don't share
it I'm cheating than the opportunity to
actually get real growth in their
business and so I think YouTube is the
best place to do it
I started 10 years ago my channel but
didn't really take it seriously until
about 5 years ago and we had seven
thousand subscribers five years ago made
three videos a day for five years and
now we're 1.8 million quarter billion
views and I'm not even that talented
I was super awkward nervous shy took me
350 videos before was comfortable in
front of the camera I was completely
embarrassed by my content embarrass I
couldn't watch it back my sister would
have to go look at it now I love looking
at have you taken any of it down no no I
love it go back and judge me right it's
amazing it's the best it's the best
right go back and see how did you ever
do therapy during any this time did you
ever I just did one today okay I do a
therapy session because I want to get to
ten million subscribers at the rate I'm
growing I'm not gonna get therefore it's
gonna take me too long so there's
something in here that I need to unlock
so I do a monthly therapy session live
with a therapist in Australia and she
pulls out memories and we do the whole
thing live and you put this on YouTube
yeah that's what I did when I left here
we went home did that and we came back
here
Wow yeah
that's that's showing the process and
showing the weakness so the thing that
came out of today's session was when I
was a kid I had I was taken to see a
child psychologist mm-hmm I don't know
why I just remember playing games and
looking at ink blots and saying hey that
looks like a butterfly right I'm like
eight I don't know yeah and she said why
did your parents take you to to go there
like I don't know obviously something
was like they were concerned you don't
just take your kid to a child
psychologist I had an older sister so
I'm not even the first child you know
like you're worried about raising a kid
so there's something that my parents
thought were was wrong with me to take
me to a child psychologist what was it I
don't know I have to find out so my
homework is go home find out I know my
next called we're gonna talk about what
they said right I think that's the best
I think showing that weakness and eating
weakness and eating any of the judgment
is the best and taking people on the
process not that I've got it all figured
out and I'm a Superman now no I suck and
I'm just figuring this all out myself
and hopefully that if that inspires
somebody to then say maybe I should
speak to a psychologist
maybe that saves her life yeah
gotcha yeah one of my questions is how
do you build a movement that matters it
starts with you believing in a cause
that matters what you deeply care about
helping people with addiction for me
it's not my my cause I love it it's
great I support you I don't hate it but
I have a different cause based off of my
pain and so what is your pain and being
comfortable enough to share the story so
if somebody's going to addiction and
they hear your story you're now credible
to them I'm not credible I can't talk
about how bad it is to be on cocaine or
anything I have never smoked anything in
my life a cigarette a puff nothing zero
real never never but you read Doritos
Dirty Dozen toxic it's brutal
da Doritos anonymous take our entire our
entire air baby here is full of like
fudge and chocolate and like tomorrow
we're going you can't be eating this
crap and then going out there and
telling people to be you know and first
all your judgment and second you think
you're a tree gonna just take your place
yeah yeah yeah bring it give me that I
wasn't gonna buy advocate motivation
listen my I'm living my life and all I
want you to do is live yours
has his morning routine he has to work
out four hours a day and he sleeps five
hours a night when he's unset hmm four
hours a day of working out for him his
balance I think he's crazy I don't look
like the rock but I can't judge the
rocks version of balance he says that's
balanced great this is my version of
balanced you want to judge me great but
hopefully gives permission to some
people to be able to go off and do their
life when I traveled it was the worst
for my health because I let things go
when I traveled now why would he I would
use eat whatever yeah instead of one day
we could be every day of the week but I
would travel for a week and then come
back so it would always I'd save it I'm
on a 90 day tour right now of the u.s.
23 cities 90 days is first time you've
done something like this no yes yes and
I did because my agent challenged me
because I'm scared letting people down
is my biggest fear so now I'm doing 23
cities not just one event I get the
chance to meet my fear every four days
and fail again right and then come here
with all these amazing super successful
people and interview and Dean Gracie OC
and hope I don't follow my face right
yeah I'm scared so I have to go off and
do it so I was worried that if I kept up
my health habits of when I travel I'm
gonna come back a whale mm-hmm 90 days
is not just a week I'm gonna come back
not fitting in anything and hate myself
for it so I decided I was gonna I was in
the leave Toronto and I'm gonna come
back Wayne less than when I left
yeah and I left at 180 75 and I'm right
now 180 point 9
so I've dropped almost seven pounds in
about a month on the road yeah that's my
test because it's a challenge so I'm
going to go do it and tomorrow Saturday
I'm gonna destroy those Doritos I'm
gonna eat like all the fudge and
everything we discovered so you like
challenges all right I like things I
like sure I like challenges that are
that stretched me and push me yeah I
will challenge you to not eat Doritos
tomorrow wait another week but I'm gonna
have my vitamins but I want to see what
you know your wife will check in with me
yeah we want--we is fine but listen
here's the thing we discovered red
velvet Kit Kats here in Arizona dude
it's amazing red velvet cake I've never
seen this anywhere
I'm sure the consequent Arizona but
here's the thing so we go in and Danny
my camera guy yeah he's we're Costco
he's buying it we'd go home first thing
he does is open up the KitKat and eat it
and he's like oh my god like this isn't
just marketing yeah this is insane how
good this KitKat this is two days ago
I'm filming on my Instagram yeah I'm
like I'm stronger than you kickin I'm
gonna see you saturday yeah and it makes
my mouth is watering I'm thinking right
now about it my mouth is watering so
much thinking about the red velvet cake
at the I'm gonna destroy tomorrow I'm
not taking that challenge don't deny me
my red that is it's kind of like it I
mean it's no but I could do that but
it's showing yourself that you're
stronger and then it may not work with
serious addiction I don't I don't
pretend to no no no that world yeah
that's that's not right but I love I do
we are not endorsing that message I pat
myself on the back for it I'm a weird
duck right like you don't have no no I
mean with addiction 100% it's white
you're the expert so I have no
credibility because it's not my path
I've never smoked anything well what am
I gonna say about anything related to
addiction I used to have this line on my
refrigerator that said nothing tastes as
great as being lean feels
I like it yeah that that would always
work for me in terms of but look I'll
tell you man that's that's why we have a
country I mean in a lot of ways what do
you think of this is kind of changing
gears yeah I look at every social media
company including YouTube including
Facebook including you know Instagram I
mean Google I mean all of them they have
people that work for them that our
attention engineers they don't call them
that but their entire job is designed to
create the platforms to make it
incredibly addictive for people because
of what it does to the brain what it
does to dopamine what it does to the
biochemistry what it does to the to the
hooks the psychological hooks so we are
you know with the process of all of the
I mean we have a lot of people that are
just addicted to YouTube to Netflix to
all of these things because they're
designed to just keep you hooked in and
keep recommending and what are your
thoughts on all of that
I think first
you have to understand and do a
self-assessment am i doing it because
I'm trying to escape most people would
rather escape their crappy life then try
to change it and learn so is the
entertainment or education most people
binge on that on the entertainment so my
life sucks but I watch Big Brother I
watch some stupid prank trick on YouTube
and I feel better about myself because
I'd you've got to shut off the world
right right I'm trying to force the
other side I'm trying to force education
you don't like your life changing the
world is open to you there's lots of
options here's some inspiration from all
sorts of different people Eric Thomas
will yell at you Les Brown will yell at
you and Oprah will hug you but it's like
the same message whoever's message you
receive better go follow them right so
that's how I tackle is I I say hey go to
YouTube but try to change your life for
the better instead of going down a
negative cycle just watching prank
videos or something really stupid yeah
the other part is if that's that's into
your world of addiction even though it's
not drugs it's something else that
you're addicted to or people are
addicted to then you need to be an
advocate for it and say okay great you
got off your heroin addiction don't
replace it with a youtube addiction it's
safer but it's still an addiction and we
need to get you to a healthier spot and
so more conversation around the
addiction side this is why the world
needs your voice because as big as a
YouTube guy that I am I don't care
enough about that message it's not my
cause I'm fighting a different cause I
love your cause I'll help you do your
cause but it's not my cause right nobody
cares about this as much as you do yeah
so you're required to get off and go
through the thing to help your mission
to help people yeah so let me so let me
ask you some questions that will be
about you and what you do but for the
listeners for the people that watch this
they can learn and do it for their own
things so my favorite in use of all time
by the way just the came to me I had to
tell you well thank you I love you I
love ya so what is working most
effectively in your marketing right now
that other people could do consistency
in your messaging and branding across
everything that you do so I see the
world through the lens of
leave every every video is about every
conversation this conversation is around
belief is being consistent so if you're
looking in a YouTube environment when we
have a thumbnail you know for anybody
who's knows my content you know what at
having comical thumbnail looks like you
know what it looks like
you mean I like it you may hate me great
but you know what it looks like right
and so having that consistency some of
the biggest guys in the industry they
don't do it and so to win on YouTube you
want to have the related videos that's
the game it's not search it's related
videos you want them to know this is a
Joe polish video because they just watch
your video they love it there's a Jew
apology video right there on the side
but they don't click on it because they
don't recognize the brand name there's a
different font and now you're using
yellow instead of the other color you
normally use and your logos aren't there
and their face isn't there you're too
far away and they're seeing that on
mobile so they don't see you consistency
in the branding and then just
consistency in the content people aren't
uploading enough my business took off my
youtube channel took off when I started
going daily every day a video made a
huge difference if you want to win on
any of the social platforms my Instagram
this is all organic went from I started
taking serious about six months ago we
had I don't know 10 15 20 thousand
followers now we're at a hundred and
nine mm-hmm because I decided to take it
seriously and go consistently what other
channels are you do you put attention on
that consistently anything else
I treat YouTube is my main Instagram is
my is my side hustle and then everything
else flows from there so I take my
Instagram content and put it to Twitter
and put it to LinkedIn
I treat them as
secondary right I still listen if you
tweet me I'll respond because the
community is important so somebody
tweets at you even if you never post
anything but they tweet you you can
write back just to know pay attention
and you want to empower those people
because they may have a following right
so if they can get your message out to
million people just because you said hey
back
would you ever outsource social media to
someone else I mean the reason I asked
that question is that a lot of my
clients is you've met some of them or
you know a lot of them rural they're
just not going to do it so but they're
like well you know I need to have this I
need to have this like this obligation
sort of thing
would you ever outsource someone else
doing your messaging for you in to what
degree would you do that it's the same
thing around marketing would you
outsource your marketing it is my well
there's well there's a couple things I
say about that it's like the two things
in business you don't delegate are the
marketing and the checkbook unless you
have a real handle on it and there's
checks and balances in place and so and
there's there's certain things that
certainly can be done it's like you know
in in some ways like you know Jim Rohn
you can't hire someone to do your
push-ups for you right sure
now this depends on how much you want to
build a personal brand you can't
outsource that if you're a thought
leader
you can't outsource that nobody cares
about addiction as much as you do with
your style your way your weird duck like
way of seeing the world nobody nobody is
the main besides you even otherwise
think of it in the way of course there's
other people who even how I do
entrepreneurship I'm a weird duck I have
different views on things I don't agree
with my Robbins on that I love Mel I
support my I share mal stuff all the
time there's some things we disagree
with but net we're both listen if you
love Mel's thing more than mine and it
works for you amazing yeah it's about
getting the result for the audience
right for for our commutative
entrepreneurs the way that you see the
world and addiction you're the only one
who could do it the way you want to do
it and so you have to be up in front if
you're not trying to build a personal
brand you're trying to build the logo
then it's just then it's the same
question of do you outsource your
marketing period as long as you have a
good handle the biggest thing with
outsourced marketing agencies is they
can't capture the soul of your company
any kind of market Direct Mail anything
they can't capture the soul as well as
you can especially an entrepreneur
because you started this business with
soul there's a purpose and nobody else
can quite understand that how many hours
a day do you spend devoted to this
YouTube yeah i chunked my entire days
now I'm on my tour it's crazy yeah but I
chunk my days so Monday is my mentor and
a mentor my team Tuesday is my YouTube
day spend the whole day recording 20
videos and doing research Wednesday is
my project day Thursday is mentoring a
interview day Friday is CEO day
Saturdays Sundays day with my wife says
when you eat all the food yes yeah with
my wife and we'll go explore is she
who's better this you or hers I mean who
eats healthier oh I eat healthier during
the week by far yeah yeah okay I you
give like if once I set my mind and
something that's gonna happen yeah I'm
gonna have to take you guys to the right
therapist here we got a figure but I'm
talking to one I just talked to one yeah
we're gonna do it privately though you
know get video do why not let's film it
no we need to get deep inside this will
go deep will go deep
what okay that's that's how you give
permission to other people to do it is
you expose everything
then other people see it and they say
that's that's authenticity that's at the
core of marketing is authentic
what is authenticity is showing the
chinks in your armor because you don't
want to learn from the perfect person
not the things that you have already
gone through and what I'm doing with
right now what in your life do you keep
private I guess you can say those things
could you things that don't involve me I
won't
so I tell stories about my parents but
only three or four stories because
they're private people I'm not gonna
disrespect them so the thing I got for
myself from my my homework for with my
therapist is to find out why my parents
took me to
a therapist a child psychologist I don't
know what the answer is gonna be as long
as it's only me I'm gonna share whatever
it is everyone used to bite his toes I
don't know I haven't used to like
whatever the craziest thing you could
think of Evan used to do that great if
it's like Uncle Joe beat you when you
were a kid
when I have no recollection of it I'm
probably not gonna share that because
I'm not gonna throw Uncle Joe into the
bus
as long as it's me if we you said
couples therapy and Nina was on board
with it
I'll tell anything you want to know and
we'll film the whole thing if she's not
okay with it then I'm not gonna do that
so Nina is fine being on camera my
parents aren't so I never feel my
parents yeah but you want to know
something about me great as long as it
doesn't involve somebody else that's
what I told my therapist too
I'm not gonna throw anybody under the
bus I'll tell you what you want to know
but I won't throw anybody under the bus
don't you okay I think that's how you
actually win like dude that's how you
get people to follow you the scariest
thing that you're afraid to put out is
the thing that you have to go off and
share it's the only way yeah I'm just
pondering this right now no this is good
that's good
all right so four things that I would
really like anyone that wants to build
their message or following whatever they
to have the best sort of knowledge for
what we can share with them yeah that
would give them the highest
possibilities heaven yeah so what are
some keys and strategies that you've
discovered for building a following
online that you haven't already talked
about I mean obviously consistency but
like what in having a certain look and
things like that I mean yeah let's talk
about someone doesn't have a camera crew
I mean we you know we're in an office
building that I happen to own yeah but
you know the vast majority of things
that I've done on video have been
holding you know even going back to flip
videos yes I used to love those things
right and so you know what are some
things that people so so just start I
will still film videos from myself and
the one you loaded up here I filmed in
my air beam be in Tulsa because I don't
know why we didn't film it on Danny's
camera we just didn't and I filmed it
and I've got 1.8 million subscribers and
I'll still
for my phone with no microphone and the
auto is not as great as it could be but
it's better than not putting the video
out unless you're an editor if you're a
video editor than your stuff has to be
fancy but you're a thought leader I'm
not watching funny I'm actually I you
say I should probably say this night and
not let this one go but I sort of have a
weird thought about thought leaders cuz
I think any idiot could come up with the
thought and so I tend to like result
leaders people in the world that
actually create a results so there's a
lot of thought leaders that I think call
themselves thought leaders and you know
it's and I understand you know we be
getting into semantics here yeah
but I actually really like result
leaders I like people that really great
but no but yeah I never get it look you
want to call yourself a pink elephant
amazing like people say can you be non
perfect
I love pig oh can you be not repair and
work in a company címon sonic like you
can be an entrepreneur working a company
who care I don't care call yourself
whatever you want to call yourself right
results leader great your results leader
amazing right I care about you helped me
get results
yeah and so I need to get the ideas or
the actions the results that you've done
and transmit them to me period
yeah and I want people from talking to
you to be able to go and get results
with right you're talking about so film
just film train the right skill for the
entrepreneurs who are just starting out
most people will do this they'll film
for 20 minutes and spend four hours
editing their video personally you're
training the wrong skill right you want
to be an editor
you want to train the skill to be a
great communicator so you spend four
hours making the video and 20 minutes
editing because you're thinking wow what
if YouTube goes away what if Instagram
goes away why I spent all this time the
ability to tell the story and
communicate in front of a camera or to
an audience will serve you for life when
you film this stuff where else other
than YouTube do you take those videos in
their form anywhere else you start with
YouTube and that's your long-form
content
let's get tactical 10 minutes plus on
YouTube mm-hmm under 10 minutes is
really hard to get a video ranked unless
your music video because they get it
from the reek licks like people are
watching on loop so 10 minutes plus from
there you look at your analytics YouTube
has the best analytics platform you look
at it and there's a thing called
audience retention that shows you how
your audience graph is going down so
basically people are leaving your videos
and it shows you when they're leaving
the videos so if every time you come on
and you're holding your cat people leave
the video don't hold your cat next time
right and you have data to work with
right every time you come on and you're
with your wife it goes up bring your
wife on more right great have you
noticed that with your wife with Nina if
you bring her on down go up more I don't
know might be she gives me a hard time
so people like that I want to look at
the analytic because if so I should
probably yeah you want you know all the
time yeah people Nina gets a
disproportionate amount of love for the
amount of time she spends on my videos
she gets too much love so the sudden
think is perceived as more annoying know
if annoying is like the the thing I'm
judging here more annoying yeah to what
in your videos you were Nina that's such
a weird question I don't know I wouldn't
say and knowing either us are annoying
I'm not an annoying
maybe I'm annoying to you but I'm just
thinking I don't know I think Nina's
pretty safe on the video so I would tell
me I guess because I might rub some of
the wrong way on something Nina gets
love Nina always get if she seems like a
very steady now is it human my my I'm
doing my event and I'm setting up and
I'm filming the room and Nina setting up
down there it's like hey Nina say hi she
weighs for 5 seconds she's on camera Oh
Nina we love you need oh my god hard
spinal yeah yeah she gives a very Nina
it's I don't know it's she's great I
mean I love it I'm jealous yeah I'm
jealous anyway so 10 minutes so many
videos
you're taking me down this rabbit hole
huh and I just chase them cuz I love
them they focus here you got you got a
questions ten minute videos take look at
audience retention I'm a data nerd like
I'd much rather look at my data and then
do this like I'm an introvert I want to
be I want to I want numbers owner
data-driven decisions that will help
grow my brand yeah so audience retention
should always be going down
people don't just come into the video
halfway through so it's always going
down but you'll always see spikes in
your audience retention what does that
mean that means somebody rewound the
video to watch that part again that's a
good part of the video right if somebody
rewound that they liked it so then you
cut that clip and you put that to your
Instagram the 30 second 45 second
one-minute clip cut that put that the
Instagram put that to your Linkedin put
that to the Twitter so you use the data
because the data is so amazing on
YouTube to help you make good decisions
that you can backup to you other
platforms yes Instagram data is the
worst sucks but there's a lot of
attention there so how do you make good
theater driven decisions and set uh
someone on your team thinking oh I think
that's the the most fire part but then
the data shows you know just like when
you do in direct mail you might love
this headline but you test that other
one imma crushes you or the other one
mhm
right it's not about your ego is about
results your results leader let's go get
some results right right respond to
every comment literally yes what it's
business I don't know why this is so
weird for people it's business if if you
run a flower shop and somebody comes in
you want to talk to them if somebody
calls you do you personally respond
every time I did at the beginning and
now we get too many comments yeah and
what most people do is say I'm only
gonna respond to the important people or
I'm only going to respond for twenty
minutes a day I think that's stupid
what would a normal business do if you
get too many customers coming in for you
to handle what are you gonna do you hire
a team yeah
I was thinking about if I was gonna do
something other than that but you but
but it happens in any business if you
are selling flowers on the street corner
well I would talk to my sales prevention
department and try to figure out how to
keep all these customers from bothering
us that's what I would probably
somebody's giving you love you right
back notice I can respond every comment
this is how you if you respond to a
youtube comment there are seven times
more likely to subscribe to your channel
okay interesting
so just showed them love right yeah
great like it makes sense right yeah so
respond to every comment now at the
beginning it was me and it could be
whoever's listening because you're
getting one comment a day like it's not
a lot of work and it may be he's fun and
you also get feedback on what's going
through the mindset right so you won't
be surprised by a button by the way some
of these I'm just literally ignorant of
so when some of these people are
commenting yeah you can tell every
person who is subscribing from the cut
laconic can you tell who they are when
you say someone's seven times more
likely how did you know that studies
data okay your is this on across the
board or just three categories I was
across the board for YouTube okay but
even if it even if it's not like even if
your niche of business is lower which
will probably be higher to be honest
right if your results leader you helped
me get results they're gonna respond to
you right right and and the result
leader that I am exactly the high you
know the nurses like that is level kids
cartoon something and to get a response
I may not subscribe right right it just
makes sense and it's just business if if
a customer calls you and leaves a
message you should call them back yeah
its basics right I mean if you have
flowers on the on the street corner and
a little in a little Vaz you're selling
everything yourself but then you get
your flower shop and you hire people to
help you how big is your team right now
so we got 24 people on the team okay
it's one guy's full-time job to respond
to my comments and put his own name at
the end of it it's from my account so
it's the branding but he has Luca at the
end and he'll save the ones that I need
to see I want to see the crap I want to
see that Evan you suck yeah like this
sucked because of whatever that's what I
want to see you know back in the 900
number
other than the sex lines okay you know
what the most probably one of the most
successful categories was if you had to
guess
help no insult line people literally
call up and and pay by the minute to
have people insult them yeah yeah it's
interesting it's funny yeah that could
be a good YouTube channel great that's
not what out and it's like
there are there are there's all the
prank channels those things below what
people would rather go negative than go
positive oh no believe me for a guy who
puts out a tremendous amount of I would
think very useful advice in all
categories of bettering yourself as an
entrepreneur as a human as yeah I mean
yeah it's an interesting world however
whatever you know look before we started
talking one of the comments I said was
you know all money earned ethically is a
byproduct of value creation which I
originally heard from my you know dear
friend Dan Sullivan the founder
strategic coach and so there's a lot of
different ways to go and make money but
at the end of the day I mean you know
put some sunshine into the world I mean
there's there's a lot of negativity out
there there's a lot of people that are
hurting I think anything that a person
can do to be it add a smile on someone's
face or help them get through struggles
or help them run a better business have
them you know be more ambitious you know
literally put some win behind the sales
I think that's you know putting good out
into the world and if you start with the
thesis that people are good humans are
good 99.99% of humans are good and
humans want to serve yeah then it then
it gives you empathy for when they're
not exhibiting those behaviors yeah
because they want to but they're not and
so something's wrong in their life right
now
mmm-hmm people that are hurt hurt others
and so the more that someone's hurt the
more likely they're going to do damage
to themselves and more likely they're
gonna do any damage to other people and
so yeah anything you can do to help them
with that all the better
it's your message the opposite of
addiction is compassion he's connected
connection in action yeah yeah great
that's something I one of the first
people that started sharing that
messaging was that I heard I mean it
looks been around for years
you know it's Johann Hari you know wrote
a book called chasing the scream and the
the thing with addiction is that
addiction is a solution it's it's a it's
not a very good solution it's a solution
that could kill you it could destroy
your life it could hurt other people but
like my dear friend gabble or mate' says
the question is not why the addiction
but why the pain and if you understand
where the pain is coming from and so
someone has to first connect with
themselves and then they can connect
with other people in a lot of ways what
you're doing is you're you're building a
whole
business around connecting with other
people using YouTube as the vehicle in
order to do it I mean I've you know
before the internet even existed I've
always loved you know three things you
need in order to sell something a
product or service you need a sales
pitch or a message and you need a
delivery system so you know in a lot of
ways here's what I have to say here's
how I'm going to deliver to people but
you know there's a million different
distribution systems but whatever could
whatever your core messages you know so
your thing is I mean even before we
started here I was asking you questions
and you looked at one of my videos with
Peter Diamandis you're like the opening
is terrible right yeah and it's like
it's um but that's an important thing
though because within that message is
something really valuable that's
discussed but right from the get-go
you're like ah you know but that's
really good for someone that knows that
area and you've really thought through a
thousand different variations of how to
open up a video so it's not just about
hey do a 10 minute video it's about
learning a certain and you're looking at
the analytics so because you know cuz
doing without data is dumb yeah and so
learning you know the data so there's
there's a let me give you the structure
then yeah if your thought leader its we
talked about spur on every comment that
gives you feedback and awareness with
your customers too even if they weren't
subscribing they're giving you feedback
like you're you see what's on their mind
things that are wild to you like oh they
hit the snooze button right yeah you get
the data from them so here's the
structure if you're a thought leader
here's what I would do lead with a
powerful opinion step 1 what's your
powerful opinion what do you believe
that is different than most people your
first sentence either monkeys are
spiritual creatures great if you
actually believe that you go for it but
I would take something like see I have a
hard time getting off track and get
because I like this is serious for me no
no right that's what I'm doing it just
to see if you're a pro or not well I
don't care if you think I'm a pro I want
to get the message out Joe let's go your
judgment I'm a tree this is great
all right so good you want a role I
don't want to throw you off any more
than that you want you have the opposite
of addiction is connection yes right
that's a powerful opinion yeah
it may not totally make sense like you
said it so many times that it makes
sense but to somebody listen first time
I got it's weird I don't know so then
you give a second sentence that that
breaks that down a little more give me
more con
tell me how that makes sense and then
you your third sentence you raise the
stakes make it more important why do I
have to care about this now like why do
I have to take action on this urgency
why now why today why people will then
move on to another video and forget what
you said
why now does it make so much sense that
alone is an Instagram video mm-hmm
you're tight you got a minute max to do
that right so powerful opinion context
raise the stakes next if you are you to
be going long-form you tell a story
what's your story what's your story
around how how connection helped you
solve addiction right and you probably
have a lot of stories right or you tell
a client story or friends story or
something in the news that you can then
talk about then you give me steps how do
I find connection what's my next step
do I go to a meetup group do I go on
lines where I go to a a do I yeah what
do I do all right and then you wrap it
up at the end that's a good like ten
minute video right and if you're a
thought leader follow that process you
will win so when I looked at your Peter
video the first 20 seconds sucked for
YouTube audience right so you fix it
right so you have your do you sleep with
your pal of opinion
give me more context racist stakes tell
me a story
give me three action times that I can do
right now and then a call to action I
love you how we want to close off call
you want to promote your news that are
lists like we're marketers you gotta you
gotta be you wanna market what's your
call to action like what do you
typically say at towards the end or
whatever what is the what is the theme
that you are doing to I mean you're on
tour right now people are coming out and
seeing you in person what is your
current way or how do you think about
directing people the biggest thing is I
want to put people on targeted lists and
actually want to talk to you after about
making one for for addiction so what
happens is we have a we have a program
called 2:54 where it takes up to 250
four days of consecutive action to build
a habit
some say 18 the average is 66 but
maximum was you're the slowest learner
of all time takes you 254 days one study
so I want to give you a video every
morning that is from somebody who has
done the thing that you want to do for
the next 254 days
so the first one we do is your own
confidence when book confidence here's a
video on confidence every morning from
amazing thought leaders for twenty fifty
four days then we did one for black
excellence highlight Nexus in the black
community then writers so every day you
get a video from a Stephen King or JK
Rowling we just launched a girl blast
for women entrepreneurs and then we're
doing self-love next and I want to do a
thousand of them so if you struggle if
you're if you're a woman who wants to
become a successful entrepreneur and
everybody around you tells you that you
can't because you're a woman and you
can't do this especially outside of
North America that's a lot of the
culture you can't you're a woman you
can't do this
but then every morning you had a video
of a woman entrepreneur who's doing it
it'll it'll change your totally right
but that series won't work for me on a
YouTube channel because YouTube if it
doesn't hit your core subscriber base
they kill the video I don't have enough
women or enough writers or enough black
people are enough of any of these
categories to launch a series but it's
important to me and so we're building up
all these different kinds of lists gosh
so I'd like to make one around addiction
yeah like if somebody knows your story
then sees Jill polish now who went from
that to this and they saw a video view
even just sharing your business success
but knowing what you came from is hope
yeah and you need a daily just because
you feel great today it doesn't mean
tomorrow you wake up when you're now you
slowly raise the baseline as you get
more exposure so that's what I want to
do across all these different causes I
don't care so much about anything the
individual causes I care about
entrepreneurs right whether you're a
writer and artist a singer anything
mmm-hmm I see them all as entrepreneurs
and so I do a call to action that's
specific to that video so if I'm talking
about a writer on the video it'll be hey
check out the 250 for writers wisdom
series every morning I'm gonna give you
a video for two and fifty four days for
free that will help you have confidence
in yourself as a writer and then you
wake up and that's what you watch every
morning yeah
it's like the most powerful thing of all
time for a lot of these people and then
you have a list and then when I go and
travel or whatever is okay guys I'm
coming into Phoenix right you want to
come see me right I'm not as good with
the offline stuff this is my first
offline thing I'm the online guy so it's
a challenge my agent challenged me you
got to go do this are you scaring it
love it so much dude so much like the
opportunities even coming here was a
wild opportunity right yeah Vina and I
have been connecting a little bit online
and interviews and stuff and I said hey
we're gonna stop in Phoenix this started
because I said I'm gonna take my wife to
every city in North America with a
million-plus people
mm-hmm and we're gonna do half the list
beginner 20 19 see here you know what's
in seen so there's a concept in Dan
Sullivan you met him today yeah so he he
talks about whenever you pursue a goal
hmm we're like say I'm gonna do you know
three YouTube videos ten minutes minimum
whatever a day or I'm gonna do one a day
you know for six months straight and you
start going down this path and you may
suck in the beginning you don't know
what you're you know you don't know what
the thumbnail is gonna write some is
gonna look like or you know you don't
even quite know what the content or any
of this stuff is but you're just gonna
commit to I'm gonna just talk about
whatever is on my mind and whatever is
important to me as you say yeah and you
start going down this path and so
there's these strategic byproducts that
will happen as a result meaning if
someone says I'm gonna run in a marathon
six months from now then what happens is
the goal is go compete in the marathon
go run in the marathon complete it but
what happens is all these little things
start happening off to the side whenever
you make a goal and you're gonna eat
differently probably not gonna eat
Doritos or fudge you know or McDonald's
french fries you just once a week just
once a week down now you might not do
that and inside and say if you ever ran
a marathon
I challenge you as a writer marathon so
I'm gonna go man they have Doritos you
could have eaten but but so what ends up
happening is all these little things and
the strategic byproducts end up becoming
bigger than the actual goal okay and so
this tour of yours is a strategic
byproduct
of doing this thing this agent that you
have is a button so what happens is that
a lot of people miss the strategic
byproducts in life I think the greatest
strategic byproduct of all time is not
hitting the goal it's being the person
who can hit the goal mm-hmm yeah it's
not I don't I don't have five years I
think if you have a five-year goal for
yourself you're thinking small
well I mean that's a context thing but
yeah there's there's all kinds of levels
five or ten your goal I think I think
you have a mission a life's purpose and
that's it to think what you who you were
five years ago to predict that you'd be
here now doing this crazy stuff
you were a different person yeah so you
can't predict going forward what you
should be doing in ten years it's gonna
be something kick-ass and awesome but
you don't know what it's gonna be you
could hit you could have your 10 year
goal and hit it
oh well nobody small compared when you
could be here's my point though which I
mean is when I pursue something and I'm
like yeah I want to do this and you know
next week okay look I'm goals I don't
want to do tomorrow yeah and then I have
things that are 25 years out you know
there's there's there's a lot of stuff
I've I've things that I want to have
live on after I die and I also don't
have the delusional belief that I'm
going to change the world could I of
course you know I mean maybe you know
but but I also don't let my ego sale you
know because well if I die the world's
still gonna go on without me you know
there's all gonna is gonna be good
things is gonna be bad things all that I
mean I don't have that much power and
even if someone does if you delude
yourself it again this is my opinion the
thing though is just in the pursuit
though just in the pursuit of the
accomplishment noticing all of these
incredible things that present
themselves to you because you're moving
because you're doing it there's there's
so much possibility and all of that and
that's so if I was to say what's the big
message here by listening to Evan
Carmichael about doing this YouTube
thing if you're currently not doing it
well if you just take one thing away as
start you know start your an attack you
know get what's gonna happen is that
momentum creates a whole nother layer of
opportunities and possibilities and
learning you know you're either as my
buddy
you know Tony Robbins says you're either
winning or you're learning mm-hmm you
know I mean yeah yeah you're winning or
you're learning and and so if you
learned a lot until you actually got to
a point where you were winning but even
at your point do you use operate with a
lot of dissatisfaction in constantly
yeah oh so my thumbnails that we talked
about if you go to any of the videos
this conferences for this just like
market news conferences for YouTube
three or four or five of the experts
will put my thumbnails up as the best
practice go copy what Evans doing
this guy has the best styles in the
industry I'm hitting my team saying we
suck at thumbnails the we suck is
grounded and we're awesome
so we suck so let's go like I want to
double the effectiveness of our
thumbnails right because it's still such
a new industry that they're still like
direct mail marketing is an old industry
and the best people have figured it all
out
oh I love direct mail it's great yeah
you figured it out yeah YouTube is new
and is changing there's always like new
stuff that's an algorithm update and now
you gotta adjust to that I think that's
actually the best like whenever there's
an algorithm update it's the best
because everybody who's ahead of you
who's whining and complaining about the
algorithm update you can go now and
crush yeah so it's it's constantly being
it's constantly dissatisfied I think I
had the greatest channel of all time on
YouTube when I should win a Nobel Peace
Prize for the work I do and I think I
suck and we need to get better every
single I'm pushing everybody constantly
always like and you have to want that
you have to want growth yeah you have to
want to get better you have to want to
make the best kick-ass thumbnails or
whatever your role is in the
organization to be the best at that I
love that I'm the only guy at my size
responding every comments I think it
will become the norm I think it's silly
that people aren't doing it it's it's
easy growth and subscribers and just
like the right thing to do
somebody connects with you you when I
connect back yeah right so we're setting
the trail for a lot of these things now
but it's because of the the constant
drive to want to get better I win mostly
because of that massive drive and
optimization in analytics and all that
more than my talent as a speaker or
anything else like Tony can go and crush
it because he's Tony Robbins and I don't
I don't I'm not close to him at all as I
speak you bring out like some fire and
energy into me but like I'm not that at
all but we'll crush Tony's entire team
is on the back end and they're saying of
how YouTube works yeah a couple other
things I'm going to babble about I was
writing something down a few weeks ago
where I wrote I'm you know I help
entrepreneurs find true love and
connection okay and I wrote that down so
it sounds a little corny but I actually
a mad
a new chapter in my upcoming book which
is you know I gave you a pre-release
copy it's called the average joe's
marketing book people can get on the
list when I release it it at Joe's
marketing book calm I thought it's kind
of clever you know what are you reading
Joe's marketing but you know whatever
you written or whatever but so it's the
average joe's marketing book because
there's 28 million small business owners
in the u.s. 21 million are one-person
operation so there's a lot of people
that don't know how to do stuff and I
learned how to you know I mean I'm a I'm
a convert of my own system but I
recently you know met the most
incredible partner I've ever had and I
wrote a singles ad using marketing to
find true love okay and it's funny
because I didn't meet her and she's
sitting right here in front of us I try
to keep her private because you know I'm
trying to keep other you know annoyances
away from her but because I can really
attract a lot of annoying people in my
life but she's this incredible woman
that you just met yeah and because I
wrote this singles ad it actually
created a standard for me to of what I
wanted and what I don't want so I'm
gonna go grab my phone and I'm gonna
pull up this thing and and I'm gonna
read it to you so it is this a strategic
byproduct of you go in and chase another
goal know that it was a strategic
byproduct me learned in marketing that's
for sure
but now you've written the best you've
written the best dating at a singles ad
in the history of singles ads because
you were trying to find yeah well and
here's the thing so there's a Neal all
I'll know if he know Evan pagan yeah
okay so Edmund pagans wife Annie Lala
okay there's a love coach and she's
absolutely amazing and I have to type in
dating here and find this thing and so
she helped me draft this whole thing and
so originally we I actually ran it on a
couple of sites and I went out well I
had a few dates
but they weren't the one they were you
know there were nice people I mean I
went out and met some some you know a
couple of great ladies however by
writing this though it created a
standard a filter and so I'm gonna
encourage people whatever they think
their purpose is or whatever is
important to them is to put words to it
because one thing with marketing see if
you think of selling is influence and
you think of marketing is storytelling
mmm-hmm you know the more influential
you are you know the better you're gonna
convert people the better story you tell
the more you're gonna enroll people
you're using your met your word around
belief you're you're going out and
you're using words and you're using a
platform in order to deliver messages
well that can be done with almost
anything and I think having a an amazing
love relationship even if you're single
or not you know I've actually started
sharing this with people me and Annie
did a podcast on how to use marketing to
find true love so someone was a search
into Google you know Joe polish true
love or I love marketing true love they
have to put true and from it you can
find a whole episode where we actually
teach people how to do this laugh and it
occurred to me that for all these years
you know even from what we can track
from my ads and promotions loosely at
least two billion dollars of revenue has
been generated from my ads and my
marketing for my clients you know I've
sold you know many millions of dollars
worth of trainings and whatnot but I
think this is a whole nother
game-changer and the reason that so many
people struggle with addiction is
because they're not connected so if you
can't connect with yourself it's gonna
be really hard to connect with other
people I think going out and teaching
other people how to do you know cuz
you're going out every day and you're
teaching you're sharing it actually
makes you better I mean in a lot of ways
and percent we're all doing this stuff
anyone that writes a book puts
themselves out there publicly in some
ways wants dead more admiration they
want the world to like them they want
and hopefully behind all of that you
actually are doing something to help
people right the point is though going
out and just putting out what you're
looking for and what you're asking the
world to deliver to you a lot of it is
just the intention behind so let me just
read this and
it's uh see what you this is what she
responded to no no no okay this is me
putting out there that this is what I
want okay and I met her okay Shh we both
live into this this here first no no
laughs all right let's see what okay so
exciting I'm not interested in changing
you I want you to relax the great start
already yeah I want you to relax into
being who you most want to be I'm here
to protect and encourage the parts of
you that are creative intelligent fierce
and tender I'll be your sanctuary and
your trampoline what I want is a woman
who's devoted to something so important
she's dedicated her life to it I will
devote myself to supporting you there
your growth and expansion will become
our priority I once read you don't fall
in love with another person you fall in
love with who you get to be around them
I want you to feel the most yourself
when you're around me this will inspire
me to do the same I'm a successful
entrepreneur with a wide array of
passions committed to personal
development and growth
I aim to add value to every person I
meet I create connections between
powerful leaders and build networks of
collaboration now my mouth is so dry
right now this is making me nervous my
high paced intense lifestyle requires a
strong woman who knows how to represent
her needs and capitalize on
once-in-a-lifetime opportunities if
you're proud of the way you love others
remain tender and moments of fear and
feel confident your ability to hold the
pain of another then will resonate well
it takes courage to be sensitive and
honest when life feels challenging I
need someone with this kind of courage
if you're in the top five most
extraordinary women you've ever met then
I want to meet you I promise I will
treat you like a queen but you have to
already know that you are one nice yeah
there's a guy I'm thinking of who would
love like what I got to get that line
for line and like he'll he'll put it up
he needs that so I have a whole episode
and what's funny is I've you now use my
mark here's the thing the strategic
byproduct is never marketing is really
applied psychology you know on yours
you're entering a conversation that
already exists in the prospects mind
which is a line from Robert Collier from
many many years ago who is a copywriter
and you know it's being able to
empathize with other people being able
to connect with other people
all of the things that I first learned
with marketing because I was a Deb broke
carpet cleaner living off credit cards
and I need you to eat in never did I
think there would then become using
those skills to help reach people that
are struggling with addiction
transforming my own you know problems
into you know betterment and now we are
helping people that just are looking for
love and so all of it you know even my
podcast I love marketing you know part
of this is just sharing the love with
people and the best ways possible so
even when you're showing me your
thumbnails I have that picture of me
holding a heart yeah I think that's
what's going to become part of my
youtube channel and I will hit you up
for that sort of thing so famous last
words
make it count I try to go into everyday
thinking that my great grandkids are
watching this mm-hmm and I try to bring
the breasts of that out and I may not
always deliver that but I try yeah and
if you if you woke up read up every day
and did something that you want your
grandkids to see you will produce
amazing things yeah well thank you
brother it is great hanging out with you
learning some stuff and get your ass on
youtube if you're not there already
awesome thank you : see you if you want
more Joe Paulus shook at the top 10
rules video me on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there that was a dead broke carpet
cleaner living off credit cards working
hard struggling doing a good job
operating with integrity really cared
but there's no relationship between
being good and getting paid